halo 5 Guardians beta gets its heaviest
update yet adding a new game type
playlist new weapon and a new Slayer map
voted through halo waypoint and the
winning map is Pegasus oh yeah this
one's easily my favorite of a lot this
large map has a nice balance of long to
short range combat offering a fun little
mixture of open areas sniping and narrow
side lanes for some Close Encounters
your bam Pegasus has multiple levels
that let you show off your parkour
skills and make it also imperative to
reach to that higher ground because the
ground level has high walls you'll
quickly find yourself a sitting duck
which sucks and of course where there's
higher ground there's gonna be some
definite ground pound rep out
yeah well bail now hmm that's good but
wait there's more Pegasus comes with the
new power weapon the rocket launcher
it's the same as usual two rockets ready
to go the only thing that's different
this time is its design and sweet sweet
sound effects and why not use this unity
added beast in the newly added game type
strongholds which you can play on regret
and Empire it is essentially a form of
king of the hill he's raised to capture
and defend three strongholds space
across the map capture two and your
team's score clock starts ticking you
can capture all three to further speed
up your points yet you run into the risk
of spreading your team too thin i
recommend storming points in groups of
three and leaving a lone defender behind
kind of works Winston Sun regret you
just find a little perch get quiet and
wait for those blood heads to come
so there it is the third week of halo 5
beta remember beta ends on the
eighteenth of January so get in there
for some wins if you haven't already
you